très bon jeu 4 et 10 dont on va faire
une petite semaine dernière
olala ça m'embête c'est d'envoyer un cv
votre gâteau de bananes bon bah c'est là
un solide à la fin j'ai dit est ce qu'il
faut le manger sur le toit eh bien je
crois qu'il faut le manger frais fait
c'est à dire assez peu de temps après
l'avoir fabriquée bon mais pas forcément
qu'elle dit à beaucoup dit on espère
juste que les froids ne pas le laisser
traîner désert où le maître originaire
ou d'être comme ça j'aurai je fais une
tour d' une tourte garnier alors le la
démonstration d'aujourd'hui et surtout
pour faire et voir comment on fait une
tourte et comment on utilise beaucoup
plus que la recette elle même car là je
vais utiliser de la patte de la pâte
brisée de la passe finisseur l'impact
c'est pas comme la semaine dernière
alors qu'ils n'ont pas brillé
c'est pas brûlé qui est fait avec la
farine du beurre pain un peu inférieur
et puis un petit peu d'eau du ciel bien
entendu cela aussi ma patte et je m'en
vais immédiatement
qu'est ce que vous allez chercher je
vais chercher une plaque beurrée avec
également un cercle à flancs et je vais
immédiatement moulé ma tournée spa
matière alors que je venais d'être ici
pour lens à loyer regardera des
quantités de choses alors ça ce que vous
allez nous montrer on peut mettre des
choses différentes dedans oui oui
absolument
c'est surtout pour vous faire voir
comment on pratique la fabrication d'une
portée d'une tourte n'a quoi que je fais
des démissions beaucoup plus que pour la
recette de ce jeu
dans trois cas où je me mets dedans mais
quoi était valable
oui ou non d'accord tu m'aimes persuadée
ce sera 13 allez-vous alors là je tu as
bien les bords c'est très important
contre le cercle à flot bien que les
cantons de certains qui a été
précédemment et de bas on fait alors
bien que s'ils étaient de rien la place
aussi été ben tu peux pas je cherche mon
petit saut je reviens ici alors je rabat
ici comme ceux-ci l'extérieur mais
j'avais coupé la pâte la révo se verra
bilan parce que nous allons essayé
essayé et réussi à cuire pendant la
demi-heure que nous donnons nous à fuir
cette tourte de façon interne et le
caire a permis aux messieurs que vous
êtes
voilà alors ici je leur part se déporte
comme cela je les peins sur une gestion
équilibrée storl mais vous le réalisez
de main de maître vous baissez la ciste
le faire j'espère je pense surtout qu'on
veut bien voilà je vais adorer un tout
petit peu mais je dors et en même temps
que j'adorerais de l'autre partie alors
l'autre partie la voilà ça va être le
couvercle en réalité de cette tour alors
je reviens ici
pardon excusez -4 et nous reprenons les
places respecter alors ici je vais faire
q la baisse n'est ce pas puisque ça
s'appelle une adresse qui n'ont rien à
voir la rue du même nom que ça vient de
moi ça ce qui est pas pareil à branges
ici pas je sais pas moi je viendrai ces
décès portent à pays
bon alors je reprends mon cher que je
crois simplement la dimension un tout
petit peu plus petit ce combat car ma
plaque est un peu juste
alors voilà je la mets ici et je
m'arrête doré le sous pas dans quatre et
nous reprenons à nouveau alors voyez où
je dors ici comme ceci luck ouverte
je vais le clic est oui et le quadrillé
c'est assez épais mais ça c'est parce
que je vais vite donc c'est malgré tout
petits peuvent le faisions un peu plus
mince
bon voilà alors je vais piquer à la fois
se font ici le couvert comme cela depuis
je vais quadrillé le couvert pour la
beauté du spectacle et si je vais piquer
c'est pour ne pas qu'ils gonflent une
façon un petit peu désordonné bord alors
ici j'ai une bande de papier
serais tu veux et j'ai pleuré je la mets
autour voyez vous comme ceux ci à vous
allez voir vous allez comprendre ses
intérêts la voilà un très important
alors certes correa oui très très
important fait incroyable qui fait comme
si bon j'ai ici dans ce tract est plié
comme un corner et je viens à repérer à
peu près la distance qui me faut pour
faire une rondelle
et pas beaucoup de temps cathédrale je
comprends qu'elle n'a pas pu la la la
l'émission sera perdue fr oui mais roger
tout le monde s'est fait un nom
d'ailleurs je me suis trompé dans les
faits une hirondelle
ce qui n'est pas grave je lançais une
autre demi rhonelle que le suis voilà
j'ai bien dis donc de papier le pot de
mon temps comme un état alors maintenant
nous sommes je cours le fond du moule
voyez vous ça y est je mets ici tant des
ricoh diaries pour n'importe quel autre
légume sexe comme ça je sais cette
recette voyez-vous la 1
ça c'est pour tenir le moule en place
alors on les récupère avant tout à
l'heure les lois assuré et je vais tout
de suite au four
n'est ce pas voilà un four comment est
bien le four chaud lui d'autres échouent
alors
je mets ça sur vous et voilà et
maintenant j'ai un peu de tranquillité
on se lave à cuire je compte pourtant
pas affolée mais je tenais à ce que ce
soit le plus vite possible
bon je vais mettre un peu d'eau je me
suis trompé dans les comportements
partir est le nom ce patriarche joseph
fois une autre tournure autre chose bon
alors ici il ya six ans et du feu alors
vous allez d'ailleurs je vais les
numéros ont fait à mesure que l'emploi
est encore une fois c'est pas
obligatoire ça non c'est vous qui nous
sachions exactement un exemple alors un
peu d'huile que voilà dans une casserole
et puis un petit peu de beurre dans deux
jours dans la même casserole
voilà bon un peu de farine ici et je
vais escaloper une petite noix de rideau
je vais en faire quatre jusqu'à l'autre
mettant puisque l'on pensait que dirige
d'aureilhan oui pour quatre personnes
alors 4 ça c'est une est ce que leurs
deux rivaux qui a simplement été blanchi
toi ce n'est pas cuit et la cuite
si j'avais la farine et après avoir si
vous voulez bien dans l'enfer comme ceci
oui c'est ça quelques secondes dans le
bouillant alors ici voyez-vous ce sont
des suprême de volaille se sont défilés
de volailles de poulet alors je vais
saler légèrement d'où cela mais qu'est
ce qu'on pourrait mettre la place au
démodé
je ne sais pas moi on peut mettre du
poisson on peut mettre des filets de
sole on peut mettre beaucoup de choses
on peut mettre aussi rien que des
légumes on peut mettre une une tourte en
fait c'est bon et bien alors voyez vous
pas et d'emblée un aspect havlat
on pourrait le faire qu'avec des
aspirations nourries bon alors je pars
in tout cela n'est que légèrement et je
vais à cuire comme ceux ci dans leur
ville tous les éléments c'est à dire les
petit filet de volaille et héricourt bon
vous allez voir pour l'instant pas des
espèces pour le moment on n'en parle pas
mais nous allons parler que vous les
avez poudré saliens vous avez voté au
passage c'est salé et poivré savoir les
mettre dans des farines et les mettre à
cuire comme ça j'ai la sécurité de ne
pas avoir les retouches et voilà et bien
maintenant je vais laver un petit peu
mais je dois tout à côté de vos asperges
vous avez une petite cervelle motors
alors on pourrait mettre la cervelle de
veau pour humains d'assurer ne pas
compromettre exactement ce que l'on veut
puisque je vous ai déjà dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de recette en quelque sorte il
s'agit que de traîner ici la technique
de la composition je vais aller voir
autour tout de suite comme un des
sponsors
ça va ça va très très bien satisfait
alors ici ça m'a bien que le mot marché
d'employés engagera la crise
habituellement voir les escargots il m'a
d'ailleurs ce mot comment ça va comment
vont ça veut dire est-ce que vous avez
intérêt à être que vous allez bientôt
pouvoir nous donner cette commande comme
vous a réclamé à les samares le diront
que c'est un jardin
des gens bon alors ici voyez vous c'est
ça a pris couleurs gérer simplement les
mettre à cuire sur un peu tout je vais
allumer sa note résout également réjoui
m très doux mais bien que le feu soit
d'où il fait
vous allumez encore un peu pendant tout
ça les sols oui un peu cela fait un
marché très doucement parce que j'ai
l'intention de faire
puis nous nous sommes alors maintenant
je reviens ici alors là je ne mets pas
d'une mais que du beurre coupé en
morceaux d'heure
voyez-vous là et je me réponds mais
l'aspect jeu la cervelle et pris des
asperges qui sont à oui j'en ai bel
aspect inverse on est en pointe
deloriste asperges doloris ce sens que
le mot norris le risque dans la vallée
vaucluse oui puisque c'est votre père
votre pays et les couper un tout petit
peu le foot hand par exemple là et les
mettre à chauffer à chauffer les biens
et chauffée par exemple hui elle se fait
alors je vais les mettre à chauffer
comme ceux ci dans cette seconde
casserole dans laquelle vous n'avait mis
que du vert que les beurs et que je vais
tenir d'ailleurs juste fondu ici même
processus que pour les rivaux si vous
voulez me faut surtout c'est ainsi
galoper non à chaud je vais mettre ces
d'esker ici quand ceux ci sont prêts
elles étaient cuites également pour
bouillon vous savez comment c'est un peu
brouillon de cervelle on aime on met de
l'eau du binaire un gros de girofle du
siège du pouvoir et après avoir nettoyé
sa cervelle c'est-à-dire mondes et
enlever la peau qui est dessus on la met
à cuire pendant environ sept à luminy
voilà grand lyon bon eh bien je crois
que c'est terminé ici nous avons pu
depuis comment une chose à faire c'est
laisser chauffer je vais légèrement
salée cependant les experts
bon c'est pas le même principe pour les
comment appelez vous semblez financier
en fin de
ça y ressemble nous sommes nous sommes
près de cette recette financière
effectivement tout près mais ce n'est
pas tout à fait ça à la financière sur
le continent sierre comporte des crêtes
et des rognons de coqs comporte des
petites quenelles ça c'est la vérité
avec le pass de la véritable renchérit
ça autrement évidemment on appelle
financière des choses que l'on fait avec
des olives du sort comme shaun deeb
financière parce que il y a une petite
sauce et qui est la seule de da mais
enfin en réalité il existe il existe une
vraie recette financière c'est pas celle
là alors je reviens pour alors voilà
bien dorés à l'or dans l'opération ainsi
qu'aux techniques ne sont pas qu'une
alors lever le couvercle royaux
l'abstrait je l'enlève tout à l'heure le
finir et le cuir
quand il est presque jet privé alors ici
voyez c'est là que devient vous avez
intéressant et bien je n'ai pas d'emploi
un plafond mais aussi par exemple je
vais coiffée avec une spatule que voit
la jeune femme ceci et cela reste
hésitant n'ai pas peur je vais
maintenant enlever ces voix là je remets
la tour si j'enlève le papier non finis
alors dans les premiers papiers puis ça
s'est fini les second papier que la nuit
plusieurs ici je suis déjà révélé la
présence aurait été mérité d'être très
coquin et rebelles de votre coeur et que
rebelle ce qu'on voulait là je vais
enlever le cercle retour demain matin au
caire
aujourd'hui ça peut être et au pardon
voici le cercle clos je la recommande un
tout petit peu et je vais finir le cuir
cette terre qui n'est pas tout à fait
très haut là mais je ne vais pas pour
longtemps
et bien maintenant ça y est j'ai alors
voile et de vous expliquer ici j'ai donc
les asperges les asper et la cervelle
comme les et attentif pour ne parler et
puis le caire en egypte en développement
qui ne sont pas sur la jeunesse et fait
de la place de la place pour ajouter
dans cette casserole les ricoh et les
escalopes vrai qu'ils sont pris
maintenant les eaux carsac lui c'est
pour ça que vous les avez vous des amis
au départ canon et puis je l'étais
marché beaucoup plus vite
les intrus ont beaucoup que lui ce
marché ça s'était crue tandis qu'on
servait l'été
jacques huys et voilages aussi alors je
vais laisser cela ici et j'ai fait une
petite sauce dans cette casserole d'eau
les routes dans laquelle il ya laquelle
il ya le beurre de cuisson
alors je vais forcer monteux au maximum
cela que je veux ajouter je me prends
d'abord une petite spatule que voilà et
je vais mettre des échalotes
je vais mettre 2 grande cuillère et
d'échalotes à cuire dans ceux d'air une
figuré et de pire et des chars voilà je
vais aller au large et effet elle aurait
passé c'est parce qu'on a eu un homme de
terrain je veux que tout cela puis petit
à petit oui d'ailleurs nous aurons
peut-être une seconde pour le répéter à
faire si nous ne l'avions pas fait par
l'a10 est bien là mais elle ajouté
simplement de la crème alors on pourrait
faire une petite sauce blanche on
pourrait faire une petite nous sommes
riches en lipides mort né on peut aussi
faire à cette sauce là qui est très
bonne et consiste uniquement d'ailleurs
aller voir celles que j'ai fait ce qu'on
peut aussi maintenant j'étais un peu
plus difficile c'est pour ça que tout
petit peu plus difficile que le père de
la sauce qu'on a vécu de faire nôtre
celle de l'année 2007
alors les eaux et si je vais ajouter une
large puis y aurait de crème aux
échalotes
dix ans jalonnés je vais aller se réduit
qu'est ce qu'il va me falloir encore un
tout petit peu plus de trains pour le
mans va vous concluez pas ce que tu as
déjà fait réduire ce qu'on fait à peu
près la moitié vous en rajoutez oui
parce que je l'affairé dire que je suis
obligé d'avoir un volume un tout petit
peu plus grand voilà et bien c'est
d'obliger la paix règne désir alors je
vais assaisonner que ça car ce n'est pas
assez donné du tout il faut du siège du
cio tout seul et nous obliger à ces
zones et vous avez remarqué que derrière
mon coin c'est surtout ce que j'aime y
accueillir un soutien de poids de
cayenne très très peur voyez et puis
voilà et bien maintenant je vais avoir
ma courte qui va être cuit en tout cas
j'espère aller je vais y aller jeter un
coup d'oeil dans une seconde salle sous
sa survie stress de très près où ça
réduit trop à faire tourner en sari du
très bien donc j'ajoute encore un petit
peu de crème de la troisième cuillère de
crème peut-être une erreur c'est tout ce
que vous allez bien toucher tout
absolument tout c'est pas déjà fait
rêver aussi très difficile ce qu'elle
est un petit peu onéreuse enfin un petit
peu plus qu'autre chose vous savez si on
considère le temps que l'on porte
alors je vais voir pour me voir et ça va
très bien
alors il est évident les voir il est
évident que quelques secondes de plus
n'auraient pas gêné mais ce n'est pas
grave nous allons regarder le dessous
qui lui c'est cuit
j'ai donc un plat ici v2 voilà je
voulais le revoir merci 4 et que même
papier dessus comme cela alors je remets
la rouerie ci dessus et ça s'est terminé
les supporter il se vide quelques
milliers de plus pour donner la couleur
à l'intérieur n'est pas très grande
alors là c'est terminé je vais
simplement le mettre en jeu ici est le
gage et je m'en vais ranger dans la
tourtière os x les escalators ils ont
assez rapidement mais d'un très
rapidement vous allez voir je reverrai
tout cela voilà qu'avec m 2 suit celle
que les cervelles
rappelons qu'il ya le ris de veau les
escalopes les suprême de volaille les
asperges les l'aspersion voilà et les
aspects et la sauce tout de suite
voici la sauce dessus voilà
et après c'est fini la cuisson et nous
allons ajouter ces quatre ou cinq as
peur pour faire joli dessus comme ça au
tour puisque nous avons une seconde de
plus le couvercle que voilà tout
simplement
et voici une tourte qui a été fait comme
vous avez pu le voir avec des choses
très ferme que nous pourrions évidemment
changer de régime alors ça se découpent
comment découper en voulons rendre
c'est beaucoup plus elle pas fait
attendre
encore là partent ne présente pas de
difficulté il n'y a pas de difficulté
puissant tout ça peut se faire d'une
passion familiale est extrêmement sain
et je crois que c'était une jolie
réalisation car c'est joli à voir
et c'est facile à faire non et pour la
semaine prochaine on prévoit de la
crainte bergère tout le mystère reste
entier
oui faut revoir catherine merci enfin
[Musique]